Director of Gamma Delta opens is 2001
film the Devil's backbone with the
question [inaudible]
the tragedy in question here,
referring to the gruesome murder of the
young orphan boy certainty in a
subsequent haunting of the orphanage by
his restless ghost in search of
recognition and justice,
what does El Toro himself a stated that
drama that unfolds within the confines
of this isolated complex serves merely
as a microcosm of the tragedy.
His question is really it
and the war goes on.
The Spanish civil war was a brutal
conflict at gripped Spain bites throat.
Between the years of 1946 and 1939 it
was a war fought and countless places
spanning the entire country,
a struggle between the fascist and
nationalist forces of soon to be
dictator General Francisco Franco and
Republican forces,
which consisted mainly of communists,
anarchists,
and democratic loyalists of the
Republican government.
When the sounds of war,
we're finally silenced on the 1st of
April,
1949 to Spanish felling as nationalists
Flag Hung Victoria's into capitol of
Madrid and it would remain there until
the fall of the regime with the death of
Franco.
In 1975 more than half a million lives
would be lost in the killing around
450,000 roughly to country numbers only
to be dwarfed by another word.
I would start only five months later.
The Spanish civil war due to its limited
scope and occurrence with the second
world war,
would dare for quickly become but a side
note in the minds of the international
community,
but more importantly,
it was an event that due to it's
indescribable savage killing between
former neighbors,
friends and family,
the people of Spain would choose to
forget and they're a national memory and
it was exactly this conscious form of
repression that broad director,
Dan Eltoro Toro to state that the civil
war,
which was never completely healed in
Spain,
is it ghost anything pending as it goes
in recognizing the lingering presence of
this national trauma and the dangers for
getting one's best Deltoro decided to
dedicated free films,
do engage,
explain and find meaning in this still
sensitive topic.
The first one,
as I've mentioned,
is what he calls his first real film,
the devil's backbone.
The second one would come out four years
later in the form of Pan's labyrinth,
and the third one in the trilogy is to
this day still to be announced.
Now,
it's important to note that neither of
these films are straightforward
historical war films.
The Devil's backbone unfolding during
the latter stages of the war is a gothic
ghost stories set in an orphanage about
to protagonists Carlos interacting with
the ghost of the murdered some something
Pan's labyrinth found the other hand
taking place in 1944 can be most
accurately described as the twisted
fairy tale of the young Ophelia.
A girl who explores a fantastical world
with the desire to return as a magical
Princess Peter Pan like eternal child of
the underworld decide Christopher
Hartney deltoros decision to use to
fantastical to say something profound
about historical makes sense.
Both of these genre seth historically
been utilized to explore and engage
chaos,
drama,
and the repressed parts of a culture in
the collective minds of its citizens.
In awards of young Ian Psychoanalyst,
Donald call check when human resources
are on the available archetype or
resources will present themselves in the
devil's backbone.
Does is manifested through the looming
presence of specters and first one being
the ghost of Sunday,
an orphan boy murdered by the violin.
Jacinto,
the oldest orphan into complex is deaf,
go seemingly unrecognized by both the
staff of the orphanage as well as the
altar boys living there.
Kai May the only witness to the murder
has kept his mouth shut and any attempt
to bring up Sunday's fate as quickly
shut down,
chaotic.
In fact,
any mentioned of death or tragedy seems
to have been deemed inappropriate by the
leaders of the orphanage.
Carlos,
the protagonist of the story is never
told of the demise of his father on the
front line and the other kids still seem
to be receiving letters from their
parents.
Parents who haven't been alive since
before.
The moment the boys respect to flee,
set food on the desolate orphanage
grounds.
The second spectrum of the film can then
be identified as the ongoing,
yet physically epson civil war or in
more visual terms,
the always lingering presence off the
unexploded bomb in the middle of the
courtyard dropped on the same night of
something's death.
The device become spiritually connected
to the boys,
restless spirit and the looming presence
of sudden death.
Both are physically debt and yet both
are shown to be alive on a fantastical
level.
Sure.
Not Unlike to unresolved trauma of the
war are asking for recognition and
guiding Carlos along the way in a search
to find answers by engaging with the
specters as similar thing happens in
Pan's labyrinth,
which a fairytale manifests itself in
the world of the younger Ophelia in
order for her to make sense or for life
after the traumatic death of her father
and his replacement by the fascist
captain vidal affiliate has been forced
to leave for us.
It into a world in which to realm of the
fantastical and in material have been
all but forgotten.
We can see this in the affiliates
metaphorical till the magical rows of
immortality sitting at the top of a
mountain and slowly wittering away.
Yes,
the people below with become too scared
of the poisonous foreigns guarding it,
I think become obsessed with their fear
of death and pain.
This mentality manifests itself all
throughout the story,
but it's most evident than captain
Verdell.
He places high value in all things
material and orderly,
but outright despises any story that
doesn't align with his fascist ideology
or that isn't grounded in what he calls
reality of the world.
The reality that for Ophelia is buddy
foreground for what lies underneath.
Right at the start of the movie,
we can already see that she notices
things that others don't pay attention
to or are just unable to see a few les
replacing of the eye back into its
proper place,
signifying the opening of a new
dimension.
In fact,
I'll throw it goes out of his way to
depict how Captain Fidel blinds is
victims time and again until he himself
is blinded at the end of the film.
Metaphorically depicting that all of
these characters that have been forced
to leave or unconsciously separated from
the realm of the fantastical and it is
not unique to just pan's labyrinth in
the devil's backbone.
I have the antagonist.
Jacinto is also shown to be bloodshot
displaying his feelings of rage and lack
of clairvoyance.
The world of the Dell and just Cynthia
was one dominated by the material,
one that places rigid and often gri
boundaries on what is accepted as the
story of the nation and of the culture
contrasted by the limitless roundness
and colorfulness of the mythological
world.
It all story in particular as one
dominated by time and is connected
obsession with death,
always checking the watch his father
gave him and physically living in a room
that reminds us of the insight of a
clock,
giving him somewhat of a resemblance to
did time and death obsessed Captain Hook
and Peter Benn is sole purpose in life
being to die and men on the battlefield
like his father before him and to have a
son to do it all over again.
He's so certain of his beliefs that he
can't even conceive of any other
outcomes to countered his worldview.
Delta Rho device is fantastical worlds
into a strictly masculine brotherly
story and a sisterly feminine one.
Both can be seen as young in stories of
self maturation in absence of the proper
archetypal parental guidance according
to professor Jordan B.
Peterson is research into recurring
archetypal symbolism.
We can distinguish between the great
fodder often representing a society's
culture and order and the great mother
often representing the earth and the
exploration of novelty.
Both these archetypes have a wise,
benevolent side and a tyrannical
destructive side.
Degrade moderate provides the hero with
the promise of a safe haven to fall back
on s he or she makes the journey into
the unknown.
Her opposite,
however,
is over protective and always tries to
shield the protagonist from facing any
adversity.
The wise fodder or king on the other
hand protects the protagonist,
instills confidence and encourages him
or her to face the unknown and to take
self responsibility as an individual is
tyrannical side,
however,
consumes the individual through jealousy
and resentment in order to sustain his
own power.
This particular archetype reveals itself
in the field,
yes,
encountered with the pill men and
ghastly humanoid creature who guards
eight lavish feast and consume some
children who tried to eat from it.
That's throw himself as stated that the
bill men represents the power hungry
fascism of Captain Verdell,
the elder leaf,
Francesco Franco and the Spanish
Catholic church also visually mirroring
the monster with these characters as
they dine on a similar lavish feast.
On a more general level,
however,
the creature represents the tyrannical
nature of to tell Terry aneurysm as a
whole is del Toro shows us a pile of
children's shoes echoing the last
generation of the Holocaust and the
Second World War in the devil's
backbone.
Jacinto functions as a similar diamond,
often shown in the same frame with the
unexploded bomb.
He is seen beating,
cutting,
and eventually even consciously mass
murdering the other children in this
feelings of power,
hungry,
rage and resentment,
revealing that he has always been the
real ticking time bomb.
On top of that,
his violent behavior has also shown to
be rubbing off on the children around
him,
which is depicted through to character
of crime.
Me who mimics this destructive behavior
during the better first half of the
film.
Even the orphanage itself seems to
represent a place that consumes the
maturation of its children with its
entrance mimicking a mouth eating.
The children who enter.
They'll toro then seems to use this to
make a cautionary statement about the
psychology behind the actions of us
antagonist.
Jacinta will so first orphan to be
adopted by Carmen and doctor [inaudible]
who would serve as his makeshift barents
of sorts.
However,
a garment is seen engaging in a sort of
oil depaul relationship with the boy and
the doctor confesses that he has never
been fully dedicated to his tasks.
On top of that,
Carmen is openly ashamed that the
relationship and mocks the boy for his
lack of a fulfilled potential.
It isn't perhaps no wonder that just
into stumped itself,
grow for lack of a kingdom gave rise to
his feelings of rage and resentment that
would fuel his desire to burn down as
shameful past.
So besides serving as a means of dealing
with the press trauma,
both Carlos and the Helios fantastical
journeys take on the role of cautionary
archetypical tales of self maturation.
Carlos in his friend's masculine journey
is one of the development of unrelenting
courage to increasingly engaged with the
repressed and the unknown.
Learning to take self responsibility and
ultimately taking on the tyrant with the
help of lessons from history and a
finally,
enlightened wise father affiliace
journey,
on the other hand is a distinctly
feminine one,
or in the words of del Toro.
And most of them,
the fantasy world I think she wouldn't
dream of,
is really going back to the valley of
her mother.
And that's the reason why she accesses
the magical realm through her mother's
belly and why the film is littered with
Fallopian imagery from the Fonz had to
to old thick tree to her bed frame.
But in order for Ophelia to return to
the womb and become a princess,
she has to show courage,
the fines towards absolute authority and
most importantly on ultimate act of
selflessness and self sacrifice in
servers off an uninvited siblings.
So when a symbolical level,
Ophelia has to prove herself to beat it,
great mudder in order for her to be
reborn as to princess.
But this doesn't mean that they'll toro
revises or sugarcoats history
completely.
In fact,
he actively seems to make a point out of
his trilogies opening question by using
similar story setups,
mirroring certain previous events,
and even using the same motivations and
outfits for similar characters.
[inaudible] by the end of their journey,
Carlos and his friends may have overcome
the tyranny of Jacinto,
but they leave the orphanage traumatized
and physically scarred.
Ultimately finding dare to Mys.
Years later in Pan's labyrinth,
Ophelia on her part is still shot and
killed by Captain Verdell.
Ironically,
fulfilling her wish to remain a child
forever,
but it's exactly in the selfless act of
protection that she makes room for an
eventual better future by refusing to be
controlled by eight baffle logical
ideology and by giving her brought her
to a generation that would eventually
overthrown a fascist regime and who now
is both a foot in the material as well
as the fantastical world,
his kingdom that was previously denied
from Jacinto.
Can you let me,
Jane,
it's true all of this that del Toro
ultimately expresses the power of the
fantastical when the archetypal,
although his characters might be faded
to remain kids forever,
their memories for God and repressed
like the real life trauma of the Spanish
civil war and capsulated in time and
nameless in their anonymity.
It's exactly in our engagement with
these fantastical tragedies into
retailing and revival after archetypical
symbolism that there are lessons skin
reemerge into our own lives,
bead in the form of another famous
eternal child and his group of lost boys
facing off against the time and death
obsessed captain hook or in the form of
numerous gothic stories or in Delta
arose own fantastical worlds,
worlds that are asking to be explored
that force us to be honest with
ourselves and our reality.
Do you have the courage to confront
that?
What makes us uncomfortable to recognize
the dangers and pitfalls along the way
whilst trying to navigate ourselves into
to right Beth to dive into the unknown,
to be reborn and then to do it all over
again?
All right guys,
thank you all so much for watching.
Again,
the devil's backbone and Pan's labyrinth
are absolute pieces of art in my
opinion.
And making this video has only increased
my appreciation of these films.
I'm speaking of Art Larson.
I just received two really need hand for
Boudin film posters from the people over
at engravers dungeon.
Uh,
every poster in their assortment is
completely unique because the pattern
and the grain of the wood are never the
same.
They make them on films as well as other
things.
And I even have one on Pan's labyrinth.
They feel great on your hands and they
also come with lifetime durability due
to being treated with a special mix of
wax oils and he handled varnish.
So if you like film posters or you know,
someone who likes him and it has a
birthday coming up,
you can use our special code
storytellers and you'll get a 10%
discount on all of their products they
ship worldwide.
So it doesn't matter where you live.
Um,
all right,
that's about it for this video.
If you wish to support us and you'd like
to get some storyteller stickers,
hop on over to our patrion page where
you can get them for just $1 a video.
Thanks so much guys.
See you in the next one.